House Speaker Paul Ryan celebrated the
moment when members voted for the bill
yesterday the conference report is
adopted without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid upon the table
Speaker Paul Ryan joins us from Capitol
Hill good morning Mr Speaker I know this
is something you've been working on for
your entire career yes yes good morning
Merry Christmas it is something we're
very excited about this we're gonna give
people a big tax cut before Christmas
and most importantly this is going to
help people get more jobs and better
wages you know and simplify the tax code
so we're very excited about this I think
people want to understand still what's
in this tax code and if you look at a
majority of it does go essentially to
corporations for a tax cut why are you
convinced that they're going to use that
to increase wages and hire more people
well first of all go to Fair in simple
g-o-p if you want to actually see the
details and specifics for yourself but I
wouldn't I would beg to differ the
average family of four in America
earning the medium income is going to
get a 2059 dollar tax cut and when more
than half of Americans are telling us
that they're living paycheck to paycheck
that's real relief when you double the
per child tax credit when you double the
standard deduction and you lower tax
rates across the board for every income
group that's real relief for families
for individuals so that's really helpful
and it's really something that I think
is needed in these in these difficult
economic times where people literally
are living paycheck to paycheck on the
business side when you tax your
businesses at such higher rates than our
foreign competitors are taxing theirs
we're losing in that global competition
more importantly US businesses are
moving abroad and becoming foreign
businesses because of our tax laws so
we're stepping in front of that we're
modernizing our tax system and we're
getting from what is really arguably the
worst tax system in the world to one of
the best tax systems in the world and
that's going to give us faster economic
growth it's gonna bring dollars back
into our economy from overseas and then
will give us better wages more jobs
that's why we're doing this just because
I think polls show that that most people
view this bill as kind of as you pointed
out as far more generous to corporations
than it is to individual taxpayers are
that are they wrong yeah they are and I
think what it is is just you've had this
big
bate on TV where Republicans Democrats
are arguing with each other pundits and
the media are saying this and that when
you actually break down the components
of this bill it pulls extremely well but
more importantly when it gets in place
when people see their paychecks getting
bigger in February because withholding
tables have adjusted to reflect their
tax cuts when businesses are keeping
more of what they earn when they can
write off their expensing investments in
their businesses and hire more people
that's going to change its popularity I
am convinced so I think there's just
tons of confusion out there as to what
this does or doesn't do a lot of people
think it's going to raise their taxes
when every income tax group on average
gets a tax cut so the proof is in the
pudding and I think the results will
speak for themselves you're right it is
confusing for a lot of people yesterday
Senator Schumer on the floor said listen
this is a disgrace we don't expect him
to say good job Paul and we don't expect
him to say that they point out though in
2027 Mr Speaker that for the middle
class this actually isn't a break that
their taxes while she go up how do you
address that yeah so first of all what
they're basically saying is we're
cutting them they're acknowledging that
we're cutting taxes for the middle class
and then because there's a sunset in
those tax cuts at the end of the decade
because of Senate rules they'll go up
now we have no intention of allowing
that to happen but it's unfortunate
because of these Senate rules that we
have to comply with that has that sunset
but Congress has every intention of
making sure that that does not happen
this has been done over and over again
again because of Senate rules where we
don't allow these artificial tax
increases to ever occur but I think to
acknowledge that there's an increase
down the road is to acknowledge that
we're actually cutting people's taxes
right now many of your Republican
colleagues who voted no on this bill
voted no because this bill because a
percentage yeah because you're right
because you can't there's a cap on state
and local tax deduction what's your
message to those people in their
constituents well first of all I would
take a look at the fact that people in
every state but but it's especially for
the the high tax states you basically
have $10,000 you can write-off for
property and income taxes to begin with
number one number two lower tax rates
we're doubling the standard deduction so
still even in those states the average
taxpayer in these groups
get a tax cut now I'm sure they're
people especially very high income
people who will lose a lot of deductions
because we're simplifying the code that
won't see it that way but the average
taxpayer in all of these groups gets a
big tax cut and frankly what you
basically have is about 46 states paying
higher taxes and their federal taxes so
you know but four states can raise their
taxes on their constituents and so for
many members of Congress who are not
from those states they don't see it as
fair that their constituents pay higher
federal taxes which are soaked up by
these high state taxes and so this is
sort of a fairness argument as well that
you're seeing I can talk about your
future Mr Speaker big rumors earlier
this week what you denied that easy
speculation that look Gail I didn't mean
to cut you off Gail but I'll stop go
ahead please I respect you too much to
do that I feel the same about you but
there were very credible rumors that you
were stepping down you of course stepped
out and said no that's absolutely not
true but where does that come from did
you say in passing to someone I'm
thinking about it no no I actually never
did that's what surprises me about this
that's why I thought it was a very
irresponsible piece to the idea that
after passing tax reform as if it's the
only thing I care about I'm just gonna
leave get up and go it's ridiculous it's
a thought that never entered my mind let
alone discussed it with anybody so I
really see this as sort of rank
speculation among the DC Beltway press
speculating these things I think that
was fairly responsible speculation it's
faulty speculation I'm not gonna get up
and leave this Congress our conference
and my responsibilities in the middle of
this term we've got so much more work to
do Gail you know I'm working on poverty
next year you know we're working on
getting people from welfare to work on
criminal justice reform on welfare
reform on all of these things we've got
a lot of work to do we're excited about
doing it and we're banking a big win
here I want to get back to work and get
more things done not least of which is
to get the military rebuilt so there's a
lot of work to do that's what I'm not
going anywhere soon all right mr.
speaker did you ever think when you are
a waiter at tortilla Coast that you
would someday be handing down the gavel
on tax tax reform so hard
you hit my probably feel the same way
you did Nora did you ever think when you
were a cub reporter
roll-call you'd be hosting this this
morning show I did not do it 60 minutes
I did not we'll see you in the new year
the end the new year take care of Merry
Christmas